drosten die frage wiederum an den
virologen wie lange wird es dauern
ein echtes medikament einen echten
impfstoff zu finden weil noch wenn ich
das jetzt alles richtig verstanden habe
können wir in anführungsstrichen nicht
mehr als symptome bekämpfen
ja das ist richtig also es ist
tatsächlich so dass man befürchten muss
dass der impfstoff zu spät kommt für
eine pandemie die uns bevorsteht
wir können eigentlich damit rechnen dass
wir einen zugelassenen impfstoff
nächsten sommer haben nicht in diesem
jahr sondern im sommer danach
und es ist schon die frage welche
abkürzungen man in den klinischen
studien noch gehen kann
was zu verstehen was da möglich ist
genau das ist sind die
entscheidungsprozesse die jetzt ganz
dringend noch mal angeschaut werden
müssen aber bestimmte dinge lassen sich
nicht beschleunigen und die vorstellung
dass jetzt der dass das fieberhafte
forschen im labor eigentlich das zeit
hindernis ist dies vollkommen falsch die
biotech industrie und auch die
akademische forschung sind inzwischen
extrem schnell was impfstoff entwicklung
angeht das was zeit kostet ist die
zulassung die klinische studien und die
regulative seite daran
und da lassen sich dinge zum teil nicht
beschleunigen weil man einfach zum teil
darauf warten muss dass patienten
gefunden werden und in einer studie und
kurorte eingeschlossen werden und da
kann man machen was man will und man
kommt dann eben am ende doch immer zu
dem schluss bei diesen überlegungen das
allerwichtigste die allerbeste chance
das ganze zu beeinflussen haben wir
jetzt im moment
wir haben jetzt im moment eine situation
wo wir also jetzt mal ganz bildlich
gesprochen wo wir hier in
spielfeld stehen und da fliegen manchmal
so funken rein und da können wir jeweils
immer noch drauftreten und das machen
die behörden mit mit aller energie im
moment und irgendwann lodert aber
überall ein kleines flämmchen und dann
kann man nichts mehr machen
und wenn man kein feuerlöscher hat ja
darum wir müssen unbedingt diese phase
jetzt im moment nutzen zum verzögern
die behörden strategien sind an der
stelle genau richtig und auch da muss
man dann wieder eben sich nicht aufregen
sondern auch noch ein zweites mal
darüber nachdenken wenn man sagt da wird
so gemacht warum wir das jetzt da anders
gemacht das sind immer auch die
örtlichen verhältnisse und
verhältnismäßigkeit also sie können in
einer kleinen stadt etwas machen dass
ein effekt hat das können sie in einer
großstadt vergessen ja also und es kommt
zu dem was die behörden tun können und
trotzdem noch mal die frage nur damit
ich nicht vergesse also antivirale
medikamente beispielsweise diese hiv
präparate ist es klug oder ist es nicht
sinnvoll mit solchen medikamenten erst
mal zu versuchen nicht nur symptome zu
lindern sondern das virus zu bekämpfen
was man da eigentlich sieht sind zum
teil auch hilflose aktionen von
klinikern im zentrum des geschehens in
china die alles versuchen was man
irgendwie versuchen kann und die in die
literatur dann zum teil schauen und so
dinge entdecken wie bestimmte
hiv-medikamente die frau die nase
inhibitoren sind und dann denkt man an
das virus hat doch auch eine prothese
das passt aber nicht wirklich
das ist also dass du mir ganz wichtig
das sind medikamente die nehmen sie
nicht mal einfach so dass überlegt sich
ein arzt sehr genau ob er das ein
patienten wie verschreibt die haben
teilweise gerade hiv-medikamente riesen
entwicklungsschritte durchgemacht muss
man wirklich sagen also tolle
entwicklung
trotzdem haben die teilweise gravierende
nebenwirkungen und das ist etwas was man
nicht einfach daneben so verteilt nur
weil es dann auch die politik oder der
goodwill der menschen haben wir dass man
sagt jetzt ich glänze jetzt in dem ich
hier sozusagen sein ich habe die lösung
das hat in der geschichte eben auch
schon ab und zu dazu geführt dass etwas
ganz nach hinten los und ja
deshalb hat die whu ja auch gesagt dass
man regelungen finden muss diese studien
durchgeführt wir haben also man hat
gesagt ich schaue mir jetzt die
datenbank in china zum beispiel an vor
ein paar wochen 180 studien die
irgendwie schon durchgeführt worden sind
zum beispiel mit malaria medikamenten
mit hiv medikamenten und dass man dann
gesagt okay es kann jetzt nicht einfach
drauflos forschen dann haben wir auch
gar keine vergleichbarkeit also wenn wir
am ende wirklich wissen wollen was wirkt
dann brauchen wir irgendwie auch ne
guideline an der sich jeder bestenfalls
jeder forscher weltweit orientieren kann
das ist ja schon der vorteil eigentlich
eine globalisierung dass diese forscher
alle untereinander mit momentan
fabrizieren nun versucht sehen und das
auch aus china jeder weiß was hätte
osten zu leisten vermag und dass wir
auch sagen
spätestens dann vorbei man wir kommen zu
der frage was kann der staat was können
die behörden tun
wir haben alle mit so einer mischung aus
verwunderung und entsetzen nach china
geschaut der 18 millionen in quarantäne
zu stellen
das möchte man sich nicht vorstellen und
kann es sich auch nicht vorstellen für
eine stadt wie kiel oder berlin oder
hamburg
was hilft es wenn jetzt tatsächlich in
nordrhein-westfalen einzelne gemeinden
in quarantäne gehen da das kann helfen
aber team muss erst mal sein
in nordrhein westfalen ist es über
diesen punkt hinaus aber wenn es gelingt
in baden württemberg einzelne fälle zu
isolieren und auch den das umfeld zu
isolieren ist das natürlich immer besser
wenn das nicht gelingt ist ja der zweite
schritt zu versuchen den verlauf zu
verlangsamen und das ist jetzt das was
versucht wird das kann man mit kleineren
städten vielleicht machen aber das muss
sehr gut abgewogen werden das muss immer
ja auch geeignet seien unverhältnismäßig
sein das wäre meine nächste frage wozu
können behörden den menschen auch
zwingen und wer trifft diese
entscheidung das infektionsschutzgesetz
gibt uns wirklich sehr sehr breite
möglichkeiten wir können einzelne zum
beispiel in hausen
die quarantäne stellen und das ist auch
dann verpflichtend und sehr verbindlich
und man kann natürlich bis hin zu
abriegelung auch dinge vornehmen aber es
muss immer in einer verhältnismäßigkeit
sein
und wer dann jetzt in häuslicher
quarantäne ist oder sich auch selbst in
diese quarantäne begibt wer versorgt den
wer geht für den ankaufen das ist aber
die gut gelöst sind es gibt bringdienste
all das gibt geht es nun relativ
leichter zeit zu organisieren dass es
nicht das wirkliche problem aber man
muss immer gucken ob es wirklich für die
entsprechende situation auch passend ist
und angemessen froschschenkel noch mal
die frage in einer auf geteerten freien
gesellschaft wie unsere setzt man da in
aller erster linie auf die
selbstverantwortung der bürger also ich
finde momentan tut man schon genau das
also nun appelliert eigentlich seit
wochen an den gesunden menschenverstand
um an herrn sparen zu zitieren und sagt
halt so was wie das jetzt hier schon mal
mehrfach gefallen ist dass man sich die
hände waschen soll dass man in die elf
sie hat immer schon so lange aber
eigentlich hätte man es auch vorher
schon wissen sollen ehrlich gesagt
und trotzdem gibt es extrem viele
menschen die jedes jahr an der korea
oder sich erkälten und eben auch wenn
sie sich nicht gut fühlen für arbeit
gehen und andere leute anstecken
das ist eine karneval ist jetzt mal das
andere also wo man wirklich sagen muss
und wir saßen hier vor vier wochen
und das wort gelassenheit ist gefallen
es haben alle ganz gelassen karneval
gefeiert und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das zuträglich war um
jetzt die ausbreitung des virus zu
verhindern
der karneval abgesagt und so aber dass
deshalb viele menschen heilig dann ist
man halt mal der buhmann aber wenn
natürlich nach gefälligkeit argumentiere
und schauen und sagen ja wir wollen auch
nicht zu großen schaden anrichten
der emotionale schaden wäre immens
gewesen dass es wie in italien wo
fußballspiele abgesagt werden dass das
löst in vielen menschen sehr viel aus
aber es ist ja nun wirklich die frage
hätte man das nicht auch mal einfach
wenn man besonnen ist damals schon mal
sagen können und man appelliert
natürlich an die menschen und sagt passt
mal auf komischerweise waren die hallen
bei karneval voll die gefahr dass ist
auch die frage und das da ist auch
wissenschaft und alles mögliche alles
gut und schön
es ist ja am ende die frage was macht
denn der einzelne mensch man hat eher
die angst
dann hat er die sorge dass er was macht
deswegen ist ja auch die eine der
theorien dass männer häufiger betroffen
sind auch von viralen erkrankungen weil
sie eben riesig dass ein schätzing ja so
dass und da ist halt tatsächlich einfach
das problem was kann ich machen und da
ist wirklich so der köder muss dem fisch
schmecken nicht dem angler
was kann ich den menschen erklären das
machen wir mit patienten ja genauso in
der klinik dass der mensch lacht okay
mache ich ich bin überzeugt ich mache es
und da ist zu wenig informationen
gelaufen bisher viel zu wenig da es auch
zu wenig unterstützt worden das kommt ja
jetzt dass die unternehmen sagen dass
man sagt den unternehmen wir
unterstützen euch dass die leute eben
vielleicht von zu hause arbeiten können
lohnt vorzeige sind dass man recht
konstante frage das wollen auch viele
zuschauer wie es im freistaat denke wenn
ein arbeitnehmer jetzt wochenlang zu
hause bleibt von wem bekommt er den
krankenschein zahlt der arbeitgeber
weiter das gehalt ist das alles geregelt
als das infektionsschutzgesetz greift
hier wieder da und mit aber der
verdachtsfall zu hause bleiben also der
kriegt dann auch einen krankenschein
obwohl er eigentlich nicht kann ja und
das gehalt wird weiter gezahlt für sechs
wochen zumindest erstmal und danach ist
es dann ein geringerer anteil das stimmt
aber zumindest sechs wochen lang
es gibt auch wirklich eine aktion
schutzgesetz eine eine zahlung dann die
geleistet wird
der selbstständige handwerker der acht
mitarbeiter hat der kann nicht für sechs
wochen 8 männer nach hause schicken das
ist das ist immer alles gut und schön
viele wissen auch gar nicht dass es das
so gibt also ich die vielen nicht der
fall sein aber es ist tatsächlich so
dass die sachen einfach nicht bei den
menschen ankommen sie werden
irgendwie lauwarm kommuniziert und auch
gerade von oben und der situation ist
damit die krankenkasse aber der seine
mitarbeiter versichert sind das schon
auch wissen wir zu diesem zeitpunkt
jedenfalls da machen wir nicht so
gesorgt
aber als wir beim handwerkermarkt als
handwerker fliesenleger der hat acht
mann so jetzt kommen die sechs war davon
kommt die hälfte sechs wochen nicht die
aufträge brechen weg
da fangen wir jetzt drinnen haben da
muss man jetzt natürlich auch darüber
nachdenken aber das ist schon ein
bisschen schwer sache ja gleich man
hätte single zu erstellen
drosten bei der nächsten frage ist ist
nach wie vor sinnvoll reisenden
fluggästen
diese fragebögen ausfüllen zu lassen und
auch abzuspeichern wer im zug und im
flug an welcher stelle saß um es
nachträglich überprüfen zu können
oder würden sie sagen wir bräuchten
tatsächlich anreise kontrolle nein also
einreisekontrollen brauchen wir sicher
nicht
es geht hier jetzt darum immer noch
kontakt nach voll nach nachverfolgung zu
machen ja kontakt racing und dafür
braucht man solche information
man wird aber ein kontakt racing im
verhältnis in der nächsten zukunft
stärker im eigenen land haben als in
anbindung an eine reise geschichte wir
werden in den nächsten tagen sehen das
neue fälle und kleine fallgruppen wie
die pilze aus dem boden schießen werden
in deutschland und wir werden dann ganz
automatisch immer weniger ins ausland
schauen was da für missgeschicke laufen
und was da alles böses zu uns kommen
kann
wir werden sicherlich mit 1 der länder
in europa seien mit den höchsten
fallzahlen weil unsere bevölkerung sehr
reisefreudig ist und auch da wieder
jedes mit dem finger zeigen auf behörden
auf politiker und auf wen sonst ist zwar
irgendwie so ein bisschen in unserer
kultur aber ist energieverschwendung als
wir haben es nur fragen man will es ja
verstehen und wenn wir eine
risikoeinschätzung also bis vor zwei
wochen war man noch besonders vorsichtig
wenn man nicht nach china reiste ist man
heute entsprechend vorsichtig wenn man
nicht nach italien nicht nach frankreich
nicht nach kroatien reist fragezeichen
herein ich glaube nein weil ich sagen
würde dass das was er draufgabe gesagt
hat längst tatsache ist und das wird
sich daran nicht messen lassen sondern
es wird sie da müssen dass dafür selbst
bewohnt wurde
aufmerksame umgehen und in dem kleinen
teil versucht hier vor ort das
einzudämmen einzugrenzen
was wir tun können so aber wenn jetzt
die türkei beispielsweise die grenze zum
iran absperrt und vier nach deutschland
immer noch flugzeuge aus dem iran kommen
ohne dass wir die menschen sofort alle
am flughafen kontrolliert
ist das klug oder das ist nicht so ich
glaube ich bin ein bisschen andere
auffassung was die reise
einreise testung angeht dass man
vielleicht bei denen die einreise aus
regionen in denen die waren nämlich
schon weiter auswahl hat vielleicht
durchaus sinn machen könnte
so also alexander kekulé der virologe
fordert tatsächlich auch das dass wir
ähnlich wie die us amerikaner eigentlich
bei jeder einreise ins land
kontrollieren müssten da sagen sie auch
das geht ihnen zu weit
wir werden einfach zahlenmäßig in
allernächster zeit sehen dass die
übertragungen im eigenen land die
einschleifung deutlich überwiegen werden
und dass es sich einfach nicht lohnt da
sein geld und seine energie zu
investieren und wir müssen eben wirklich
diese investitions frage in allen
sparten stellen
es ist hier nicht so dass irgendjemand
versäumt hat ganz viele stellen in
vorbereitung auf die pandemie zu
schaffen
eine pandemie ist eine zeitweise
auftretende ausnahme situation in der
alle zusammenarbeiten und improvisieren
müssen das geht nicht ohne improvisation
und zur improvisation gehört eben das
sinnvolle investieren der wenigen kräfte
die man einfach hat und das verzögern
das zeitliche verzögern und auch vor
allem eine gewisse bewusstheit die sich
in deutschland noch nicht eingestellt
hat wir haben was ganz interessantes
vorgestern gehört von den amerikanischen
cdc centers for disease control also die
oberste solchen kontrollbehörde dort ist
letztlich das amerikanische
robert-koch-institut da hat eine sehr
hochrangige abteilungsleiterin offiziell
gesagt wir bitten die bevölkerung um
mithilfe
das ist der erste aspekt und der zweite
aspekt ihrer aussage war
wir bitten die bevölkerung um mithilfe
in der erwartung dass es schlimm werden
wird und das ist etwas das wir hier in
deutschland genauso sagen können wir
haben hier dieselben strukturen und es
kann schlimm wenn es wird schlimm werden
und wir werden alle auf eine gewisse art
und weise gemeinsam hier an
improvisieren müssen
herr dr im anschluss werden also ob
jetzt behörden überreagiert haben oder
richtig reagiert haben oder zu wenig
reagiert haben wird man das eigentlich
erst nach einer solchen epidemie oder
pandemie sagen kann wir haben ja keine
seherischen fähigkeiten also ich weiß
nicht ob mir irgendwie widerspricht ich
glaube dass wir uns einig natürlich muss
ich im nachhinein muss ich auch schauen
was ist gut gelaufen und was nicht und
wir sind ein land das hat viele
ressourcen wir haben die richtige
mentalität bei den menschen
es wird gemeinsam angepackt also sind
auf dem richtigen und guten weg aber das
habe ich auch gesagt man hätte
vielleicht ein bisschen vorhersagen
müssen zieht euch warm an das wird
ungemütlich und wie ungemütlich das muss
man dann halt mal schauen ich auch meine
frage stand rang das wenn man jetzt den
karneval abgesagt hätte dass das klar
das nimmt freude aber sorgt es nicht
auch für extreme angst und übertriebene
panik also das finde ich ist es die
verhältnismäßigkeit die da zählen und in
dem moment in dem zustand in dem
deutschland war
und wenn wir sagen wir schauen auf uns
dann würd ich sagen diese
verhältnismäßigkeit war eben noch nicht
gegeben
das ist immer die frage muss man schauen
aber das wird werden auch die zahl
zeigen aber wir haben jetzt die ersten
wir haben noch gar nicht so viele
infizierte und da ist karneval ein
kernthema
und da kann man nicht sagen das hätten
wir besser nicht abgesagt also ich bin
da lieber vorsichtig als nachsicht ich
das nicht vielleicht auch in der natur
eines mediziners so und dann die frage
noch mal als allerletztes härtesten wenn
wir jetzt über große veranstaltung
nachdenken nicht nur fußball morgen wird
entschieden ob die itg hier in berlin
die tourismusbörse abgesagt wird
da sagen sie das ist richtig und
angemessen oder bleibt es in der balance
das von fall zu fall zu entscheiden
man muss das immer von fall zu fall
entscheiden und das ist auch einer der
gründe warum wir natürlich die den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst bis in
die verästelungen der kommunen hinein
haben weil die einfach die situation vor
ort am besten sein kennen und besser
einschätzen kann
gut ich darf mich bei ihnen ganz
herzlich bedanken in dieser runde und
gäbe sofort live und in farbe zu markus
lanz weiter der heute unter anderem
katja kipping zu gast hat wir sehen uns
wenn sie mögen nächsten donnerstag
wieder zwang
15 gleiche stelle gleiche
[Applaus]